speaking of sort of challenges and hard
things is there a possible world
where sitting in a room with mark
zuckerberg
with a one billion dollar deal
you turn it down
yeah of course
what does that world
look like why would you turn it down why
did you take it what was the calculation
that you were making ah thus enters the
world of
counterfactuals and not really knowing
and if only we could run that experiment
well the universe exists it's just
running in parallel to our own yeah
it's so fascinating right um
i mean we're talking a lot about money
but the real question was
um i'm not sure you'll believe me when i
say this but
could we strap our little company onto
the side of a rocket ship
and like get out to a lot of people
really really quickly with the support
with the
the talent
of a place like facebook i mean people
often ask me what i would do differently
um at instagram today and i say well i
probably hire more carefully because we
showed up
just like before i knew it we had like
100 people on the team
and 200 and 300 i don't know where all
these people were coming from i never
had to recruit them i never had to
screen them they were just like internal
transfers right
so it's like relying on the facebook
hiring machine which is quite sort of
i mean it's an elaborate machine it's
and it's great by the way they have
really talented people there
but my point is um
the choice was like take this thing put
it on the side of a rocket ship that you
know is growing very quickly
like i had seen what had happened when
ev sold blogger to google and then
google went public remember we sold
before facebook went public
there was a moment at which the stock
price was 17 by the way facebook stock
price was 17 i remember thinking what
the f did i just do right
uh now at
320-ish i don't know where we are today
but like
okay like
the best thing by the way is like
when the stock is down everyone calls
you dope and then when it's up they also
call you a dope but just for a different
reason
right like you can't win lesson in there
somewhere yeah so but you know the
choice is to stripe yourself to a rocket
ship or to build your own you know mr
elon built his own
literally with the rocket ship
that's a difficult choice because um
there's a world
actually i would say something different
which is elon and others decided to sell
paypal
for
not that much i mean how much was it
about a billion dollars i can't remember
something like that yeah i mean it was
early and um but it's worth a lot more
an hour and then build a new rocket ship
so this is the cool part right if you
are
an entrepreneur and you own a
controlling stake in the company
not only is it really hard to do
something else with your life because
all of the
you know value is tied up in you as a
personality attached to this company
right
but if you sell it and you get yourself
enough capital and you like have enough
energy
you could do another thing or 10 other
things or in elon's case like a bunch of
other things i don't know like i lost
count at this point um
and it might have seemed silly at the
time and sure like if you look back man
paypal's worth a lot now right
but i don't know like do you think elon
like cares about like are we gonna buy
pinterest or not like i just he is
he created a a a massive capital that
allowed him to do what he wants to do
and that's awesome that's more freeing
than anything because when you are an
entrepreneur attached to a company you
gotta stay at that company for a really
long time it's really hard to remove
yourself but i'm not sure how much he
loved paypal versus spacex and tesla
i have a sense that you love
instagram yeah i loved enough to like
work for six years beyond the which is
rare which is very rare you chose but
can i tell you why sure it's um
please
there are not a lot of companies that
you can be part of where
the pope's like i would like to sign up
for your product like i'm not a
religious person at all
i'm really not um yeah but when you go
to the vatican and you're like walking
among the giant columns and you're
hearing the music and everything and
like
the pope walks in and he wants to press
the sign up button on your product like
it's a moment in life okay um no matter
what your persuasion okay
the number of doors and experiences that
that opened up was it was incredible i
mean the people i got to meet the places
i got to go
um i assume maybe like a payments
company is slightly different right
but that's why like it was so fun and
plus i truly believed we were building
such a great product and i loved loved
the game it wasn't about the money it
was about the game
do you think do you think he had the
guts to say no
is that so his i often think about this
like
how hard is it for an entrepreneur to
say no because
the peer pressure so every like
basically the sea of entrepreneurs in
silicon valley are going to tell you
this is their dream
the the the thing you were sitting
before was is a dream to walk away from
that is really
it seems like nearly impossible
because instagram
could in 10 years
be you know you could talk about google
you could be making self-driving cars
and building rockets that go to mars and
compete with spacex totally and so
that's an interesting decision to say
am i willing
to risk it and the reason i also say
it's an interesting decision because
it feels like per previous discussion if
you're launching a social
uh social network company
there's there's going to be that meeting
whatever that number is if you're
successful if if you're on this rocket
ship of success there's going to be a
meeting with one of the social media
social network companies
that want to buy you
uh whether it's facebook or twitter but
it could also very well be google who
seems to
have like a graveyard of failed social
networks
and it's
i mean i don't know i i think about that
how difficult it is for an entrepreneur
to make that decision
how many have successfully made that
decision i guess
it's a big question it's sad to me to be
honest that too many make that decision
perhaps for the wrong reason to to sorry
when you say make the decision you mean
to the affirmative through the
affirmative yeah got it yeah there are
also companies that don't sell right and
take the path and say we're going to be
independent and then you've never heard
of them again
like i remember uh path right was one of
our competitors early on
uh there's a big moment when they had i
can't remember what it was like a 110
million dollar offer from google or
something
it might have been larger i don't know
um
and i remember there was like this big
techcrunch article that was like they
turned it down after talking deeply
about their values and everything and
i don't i don't know the inner workings
of foursquare but like i'm certain there
were many conversations over time where
there were companies that wanted
foursquare as well um recently
like
i mean what other companies
there's clubhouse right like i don't
know maybe people were really interested
in them too
like
there are plenty of moments
where people say no
and we just forget that those things
happen we only focus on the ones where
like
uh they said yes and like wow like what
if they had stayed independent so i
don't know i like i used to think a lot
about this now i just don't because i'm
like whatever i
you know like things have gone pretty
well yeah yeah i'm ready for the next
game i mean think about um an athlete
where
i don't know maybe they they they do
something wrong in the world series or
whatever and like if you let it haunt
you for the rest of your career like
why not just be like i don't know it was
a game next game next shot right and if
if you just move to that world like at
least i have a next shot right no that's
that's beautiful i mean just in insights
uh and it's funny you brought up
clubhouse it is very true it seems like
clubhouse is uh
you know
on the downward path and it's very
possible to see
a billion plus dollar deal at some stage
maybe like a year ago or half a year ago
from facebook from google i think
facebook was flirting with that idea too
and i think a lot of companies probably
were
i wish it was more public
you know what there's not like a badass
public story about them making the
decision to walk away we just don't hear
about it and then we get to see the the
results of that success or the failure
more often failure
so a couple things one is i would not
assume clubhouse is down for the count
at all they're young they have plenty of
money they're run by really smart people
i'd give them like a very fighting
chance to figure it out there are a lot
of times when people call twitter down
for the count and they figure it out and
they seem to be doing well right yeah um
so just backing up like and not knowing
anything about their internals like
there's a strong chance they will figure
it out and that people are just down
because they like being down about
companies they like assuming that
they're gonna fail so who knows right
but let's take the ones in the past
where like we know how it played out
there are plenty of examples where
people have turned down big offers and
then you've just never heard from them
again but we never focus on the
companies because you just forget that
those were big but inside your psyche
i think they're um
it's easy for someone with enough money
to say money doesn't matter which i
think is like it's [ __ ] of course
money matters to people
um
but at the moment you just can't even
grasp like the number of zeros that
you're talking about it just doesn't
make sense
right
so to think rationally in that moment is
not something many people are equipped
to do especially not people where i
think we had founded the company a year
earlier maybe two years earlier like a
year and a half we were 13 people
but um i will say
i still don't know if it was the right
decision because i don't have that
counterfactual i don't know that other
world
i'm just thankful that
by and large most people love instagram
still do
by and large people are very happy with
like the time we had there
um and i'm proud of what we built so
like i'm cool like we're you know now
now it's it's next shot right
you